the mission of the mobile experience lab
is to design and rethink connectivity
between people information and places
and we try to reinvent median
technologies to improve how people
communicate and how people interact with
the physical space we were interested
basically in everything in mobility from
two perspective how people move within
the physical space within the city and
secondly how people move around
information so how you can rethink the
cognitive mobility one of our project is
locust it is a content management system
which allow us to quickly prototypes new
ideas and basically integrate web and
mobile and platforms and also wearable
platforms lot of students and users
using our system in order to map the
city and trying to understand what kind
of problems
the city had in particular one day after
big storm in Brazil there was a battle
on the street and this was very
dangerous for cars so one student
started to film and send this
information to the local municipality
asked him to fix the street but nothing
happened so local businesses in this
area they started to put a puppet on the
pothole in order to signal to cars how
dangerous was the situation and this guy
was Tim Feeny in the profit
are you working and he narrowed the
story from the day one when the battle
started till when the municipality
finally came and fixed the street
through video innovations we were able
to communicate in a timely manner and in
the geo-located way how you can inform
the municipality about things that can
be dangerous for pedestrians and for the
local businesses and for cars they
connect a sustainable home it is a
project that we started three years ago
we are exploring new forms of energy
production and management how you can we
imagine the way information and
communications technologies can support
a connected sustainable home
our house has a dynamic facade it is a
very sophisticated facade the house
behave automatically in order to
optimize the energy production and
consumption so this is a very
sophisticated project implies a mix
between material science artificial
intelligence and robotics probably what
is specific to our group is that we work
always in multidisciplinary teams and we
try to cross pollinate a different field
of research the main goal of the mobile
experience that we still how you can
creatively design technologies in order
to improve the connectivity between
people places and information
[Music]